INTRO:
Over the past decade,
the reputation of oil companies have only
gotten worse and worse. Not only do they
contribute to climate change, but they’re also
actively draining Earth’s natural resources.
So, it’s not surprising that many have been
supporting renewable forms of energy as much as
possible from buying electric cars to installing
solar panels. Despite their efforts though,
our society is still very much dependent on oil
whether its to run factories or to fuel planes.
And, it’s no secret that oil prices have
skyrocketed over the past several months.
This has caused gas prices to reach nearly $5 per
gallon across the US. While this is terrible for
everyday people who are just trying to make
ends meet, this has been a blessing for oil
companies. Exxon’s net profits, for example, have
jumped from all time lows to multi year highs,
and this has sent the stock soaring. From
the pandemic bottom, Exxon has skyrocketed
250% which correlates to a market cap gain of
$314 billion. This has served oil investors
like Warren Buffett extremely well, but this is
also a terrible economic sign and here’s why.
WHY IS OIL MOONING?:
Before we jump into why this is terrible for
the economy, we should first take a look at
why oil prices are skyrocketing in the first
place. At first glance, it’s easy to just blame
higher oil prices on sky high inflation,
but really, it’s not as a simple as that.
There’s a multitude of reasons behind this rise
starting with an unprecedented surge in demand.
Most people have been cooped up inside their
homes eversince the pandemic started. And now
that covid cases are finally subsiding, people
are more excited than ever to leave their city,
state, or even country. Whether its a simple
vacation or a trip to meet family in different
states or countries, people are willing to
spend significant amounts to get out. And
given that aviation industry accounts for 7.8%
of global oil consumption, it’s not surprising
that this V shaped recovery in airline demand has
contributed to a V shaped recovery in oil prices.
But, the contribution of airlines is nothing
in comparison to the contribution of road based
vehicles which has also boomed. We’re seeing more
people go to stores, malls, theathers, concerts,
music festivals, road trips, etc. But, even more
importantly, most companies have started to call
back their remote employees which has led to
one hour commutes becoming the norm once again
for many. And with leaders like Elon Musk waging
a full on war against remote work, it’s just a
matter of time until more companies call back all
of their employees. And with passenger cars and
freight vehicles accounting for 49.3% of global
oil consumption, it’s no wonder that a return to
normalcy has increased demand substantially. Aside
from increasing demand, we’ve also been facing a
major geopolitical conflict which is of course the
Russia Ukraine war. Much of the world sides with
Ukraine and to show their allegience, they’ve been
boycotting Russian goods. The US, for example,
has shut off imports of Russian oil, natural gas,
and coal. Russia only accounts for about 10% of
the global oil supply, but this itself makes them
one of the top three oil producers in the world
only beaten out by the US and Saudi Arabia. So,
cutting of Russian oil not only reduces supply,
but it also gives other oil producers more
pricing power. One of the main reasons that
oil got so cheap in during the pandemic was
actually thanks to Russia. You see, Russia and
Saudi Arabia were having an oil war during the
pandemic which pumped up oil production to 30
year highs while demand was at all time lows. This
even led to oil prices going negative momentarily.
But now, we no longer have Russia to play these
crazy commodity games. And speaking of commodity
games, the people who are most notorious for such
games are no doubt Wall Street. A solid portion
of Wall Street has been speculating for oil
prices to go up eversince the pandemic started,
but wait a minute, how does Wall Street buying oil
futures have anything to do oil prices themselves.
After all, it’s not like hedge funds are directly
buying barrels of oil. They’re basically just
betting on whether oil will go up or down in the
coming months and years. Well, here’s the thing,
when Wall Street has optimistic expectations for
oil prices, oil producers are less wiling to sell
their oil because theoretically, according to Wall
Street, they should be able to sell their oil for
a higher price in the future. On the flipside, oil
consumers get more desperate to buy oil right now
because, according to Wall Street, it’s only gonna
get more expensive. So, while Wall Street doesn’t
directly contribute to the supply and demand of
oil, they play quite a significant psychological
role. And when you combine historic inflation, a
v shaped recovery in demand, the Russian boycott,
and Wall Street speculation, it’s no wonder
why oil prices are going to the moon.
ECONOMIC HARDSHIP:
Now that we have a better understanding as to why
oil prices are skyrocketing in the first place,
we can move onto its impact on the economy. In
terms of microeconomics, I don’t even think I
need to explain anything. For most of us, gas is
an essential. You need it go to work, shop for
groceries, drop kids off at school, etc. Even if
you rely on public transportation like busses and
subways, it’s only a matter of time until ticket
prices and annual passes increase accordingly.
So, sooner or later, we’ll all be forced to
allocate more money towards transportation.
For many, this increase is enough to break
the bank, especially for those living in
high cost states like California. But, even
if you’re able to afford the increased cost,
you’re remaining budget will no doubt decrease
which means less discretionary spending.
And given that consumer spending is directly
linked to GDP, this is not the best of signs.
To make things worse, its not just everyday
people who are feeling the weight of increasing
oil prices either. Companies are very much
feeling the impact as well. Now of course,
there are companies that aren’t dependent on
a physical product like Facebook or Google.
But, most companies do rely on shipping in one
form or another whether we’re talking about Apple
and Amazon or Nvidia and Tesla. And as oil prices
boom, so does the transportation expenses for
these companies. Also, many of these companies
already run on extremely thin profit margins,
so increased logistical expenses alone are enough
to push them into unprofitability. For example,
even Amazon who has one of the most established
and efficient logistical channels in the world
is feeling the pain. Last quarter, Amazon’s retail
busines was unprofitable both in North America and
internationally. Usually, this wouldn’t be that
big of a problem as companies can just pass on
the increased cost to customers. But, given that
people already have less discretionary income,
they’re more sensitive to price increases. In
fact, one survey found that 1 in 3 prime members
were considering cancelling their subscriptions
due to the price hikes at the beginning of the
year. So, many companies are stuck in this
situation where they have increasing expenses
but stagnating or even declining revenue. This
problem is made even worse when you consider
that companies won’t be able to achieve the
same economies of scale with less revenue.
So, their cost per dollar of revenue just becomes
even worse. And in such circumstances, there’s
only one obvious option and that’s layoffs. We’re
already seeing a slew of signs that companies are
getting desperate to hold up revenue. For
example, we’re hearing rumors that Amazon
might have another Prime day in the Fall. And the
timing of this is especially concerning. The fall
is usually the best time for companies thanks
to the holiday season. So if Amazon is already
trying to boost numbers for this fall, how
bad will demand be in q1 and q2 of next year.
Clearly, we’re already starting to see the
first signs of decreasing demand appear. And,
if oil prices continue to stay at historically
high levels, things will likely only get worse.
RECESSION INDICATOR:
As companies’ earnings slide and people spend
less money, we’ll see the rest of the economy
follow a downward trend as well. Here’s the
thing, when companies earnings are declining,
who wants to be investing in companies. Now
of course, some of you contrarians out there
are saying that this is the best time to buy
fundamentally strong companies for the long term.
And, you may very well be right, but the mob is
not on your side. If they were, the stock market
wouldn’t be going down in the first place. So,
this means that we’re not only facing decreasing
consumer spending, but we’re also facing
decreasing investing. Usually, in such scenarios,
the government would pump up spending, but
they’re also pulling back substantially to
fight high inflation. So, consumption, investment,
and government spending are all going down meaning
that our GDP is basically screwed atleast in the
short to medium term. And given that a recession
is defined by two successive quarters of GDP
decline, chances are pretty good that we enter a
recession. Skyrocketing oil prices have actually
been extremely good at predicting recessions
historically. Not every recession is characterized
by high oil prices, but everytime oil
prices are high, we have a recession, and this has
been true since the 1940s. Between 1946 and 1948,
we saw oil prices nearly double. And shortly
after we saw a recession between 1948 and 1949.
Similarly, between 1973 and 1974, oil prices
nearly tripled, and we once again saw a
recession. We saw the same thing between 1979
and 1980, and 1990 and 1991, and 1998 and 2000,
and 2007 and 2008. In fact, I don’t think there’s
a single time in this 70 year graph where oil
prices spiked and there wasn’t a recession. Now
of course, correlation does not mean causation,
but considering all of the reasoning that we’ve
already discussed throughout this video, it
doesn’t seem like this is just a coincidence
either. To make things worse, the most recent
spike is more violent than we’ve ever seen with
oil rocketing from $20 to $110 within a matter
of two years. So, based on history,
things aren’t looking that bright.
THE LIGHT AT THE END:
While we may very well be in
for a painful recession and rising unemployment,
there are some brightspots to look forward to.
Not all recessions are accompanied by a stock
market crash, but given how the market has been
performing so far, it definitely looks like
this recession is being accompanied by one.
On average, indices typically peak 7 months before
a recession and the bottom 4 months before the end
of a recession. Given that the S&P 500 peaked
in December, that would mean that the recession
is starting right now. We don’t know when it’ll
end but historically, right now and the coming
months would be the best time to buy into indices
and fundamentally strong companies. As for the
housing market, I don’t think there’s going to be
a full on crash like 2008 or anything, but a cool
down is extremely likely and this could help many
people buy their first home without having to bid
insane amounts over asking. Aside from providing
a great buying opportunity, recessions generally
wipe out the garbage on the market. And there’s
not doubt loads of garbage within the stock market
and especially the cryptocurrency market. I mean,
I don’t even think we need to discuss NFTs or
all of the dog faced coins on the market. So,
this could be a great time to cleanse the space
and start fresh. There may be some non financial
benefits as well. With gas prices being so high,
it’s likely that many upper middle class
families will make the jump to EVs,
and this would be a great boost for the entire
industry. But most importantly, a recession may
help cool down the out of control inflation that
we’re currently facing. And that may be just what
we need to transition into a new period of growth
and prosperity, but that’s just what I think. Do
you think we’re in a recession? Comment that down
below. Also, drop a like if you can’t wait to get
to the otherside of this recession. And of course,
consider joining our discord community to suggest
future video ideas and consider subscribing
to see more questions logically answered.